Let’s summarise what we have learned in
this lecture.
MATLAB supports a number of operations between
matrices and scalars, and matrices and matrices.
In the case of a matrix and a scalar, what
happens is that the scalar is applied to every
element of the input matrix and those results
are placed into the corresponding elements
of the output matrix.
The sorts of operators we can use between
a matrix and a scalar include the standard
arithmetic operators and they also include
the logical operators, which perform logical
comparisons, and which have a result which
is either true of false.
When we perform an operation between a matrix
and a matrix, the matrices need to be the
same size and the operations are performed
between corresponding elements of the matrix.
Results are placed into the corresponding
element of the output matrix.
MATLAB supports a number of logical operators.
The results of logical operator are only true
or false and we can perform a number of different
logical tests: equality; non-equality; greater
than; less than; and so on.
We have talked about monadic image processing
and that is where individual pixels in the
input image are passed through a function
f(x) and the result is placed into the corresponding
element in the output matrix.
We apply the same function to all pixels and
we looked at a number of operations such as
contrast; enhancement; brightness change;
histogram normalization; thresholding; posterization;
and so on.
And there are many, many, more.
The other class of operation we looked at
are what we called diadic operations and here
we have two input images, passed through a
function and the output value is placed into
the corresponding pixel in the output image.
Some examples of diadic operations were image
subtraction, which we used to find the difference
between two input scenes.
We also used the number of different diadic
operations in performing quite a sophisticated
image processing task, which is implementing
the green screen effect.